[Music]
20 international chess professionals
converge here in st. Louis for the 2017
winter chess classic hello chess fans
bensimon here with another recap today
is round six of the winter chess classic
as we approach the final round here in
st. Louis we start to see a few players
being mathematically eliminated from
contention still there are some great
games to be played even for them these
players will earn top level tournament
experience but also there's a
twenty-thousand-dollar prize fund at
stake the winner of group a nets $5,000
the winner of Group B that's four
thousand dollars in Group A i'm sitting
here with grandmaster jaroslav is there
a book who just defeated roofing Lee
with the black pieces congratulations on
the victory like and you're not out of
the running yet with this victory with
three out of six still near the top and
there's still a lot going for you so
yarrow if you would please take us
through the game and show us some
interesting points well I felt you even
if objectively the computer will show
something here of four white some
advantage still a position is so complex
human being you know the three results
can happen yeah and this here I guess he
just completely underestimated my
counter play maybe he assume that he's
just winning up there for but I came up
here with this nice defensive ad in 94
and then Queenie seven and the
uniqueness of the position is that I'm
down bishop and the rook but but seems
like why just has no defense because my
threats are too strong and the kingdom
g8 now is very safe yeah I guess here
White is just lost at least I couldn't
find any defense for him and also keep
able to find any appropriate defense
during the game so
so the point is I want to go clean III
check when you want check bishops III is
an idea and so somehow white is just
unable to defend properly if night be
one then there should be two mates of
course and and if some work moves like
review three here i calculated Queenie
one maybe one then I give him checks and
let's say in this position is Queen on
c6 as the main reason she loses I just
go would say you're away 92 and 95 so
good enough I think maybe 92 is there oh
wow it doesn't really matter then quite
I take the Queen probably probably
actually here so my bishop is not
hanging just in case yeah so so he
couldn't believe his eyes which is
happening here but i was already like
okay victory is mine you know so yeah so
he could totally mess this I mean maybe
he was too confident for some reason I
mean we played we played a one game
before cervical classical game and I was
in terrible shape and determined I want
to play in Houston and then he beat me
but uh in five games i was like twice
and most likely 15 rating points so it
wasn't tournament took my life for sure
and I guess maybe Basin best experience
he expected to beat me you know like
awesome meters how long ago was that I
was like yeah it wasn't 2015 okay yes
and but then I remember while we play
blitz of the world open and I beat him
one and a half to half yeah but still so
yes happy to find this ad and and then
I finish him I guess who pretty clearly
like without any chances because well in
this sermon I had to winning positions
against Allah save and also against
positive as much better but then I
managed to blunder so in this game I'm
like okay just make sure you're not
going to blunder anymore you know at
some point you should stop blundering if
you want to get some point right in the
term yeah so here I pulled myself
together and funds how to win properly
really aight i guess was a good idea and
I think the fastest way to win the
Queen's if Bishop g6 then I can just
take take on before I believe although
well actually I also thought if Bishop
g6 I can i have multiple ways I was
considering Queenie to the it is Queen B
1 and if Quincy 3 and Queen B 1
initially actually in this given in this
game somehow I managed to a sort of
blunders in my calculation like this
point not actually the one he played
Bishop c4 from yeah from this position I
was calculating okay bishops III and
then I reached a disposition my
calculations and I thought okay come on
it's just an easy when Queenie to Quincy
three and I thought okay I'm taking the
rock on each one but then 27 [ __ ] me
not very nice surprise well well to
justify my calculation it was kind of
like pretty long calculation right but
then but then I'm like none argued bc is
Bangladesh made made the one is not a
bad thing to miss you when you complete
the winning yeah so and then well this
is this is completely lost but in the
end I I couldn't read can reject this
Bishop e1 inches
most beautiful one because he resigned
his photos made it was coming yeah well
roofing Lee always a very important
person to defeat he's a very notable
junior regular in the US Junior
Championship and many other strong
tournaments such as this one so you're
still in contention in group a the the
range of scores in Group A is a lot less
dynamic than that of Group B there's a
lot of people still at the top of course
David Howell has maintained that lead
for a few rounds now but you face him
tomorrow what can you talk about your
mindset going into this game uh honestly
I don't expect much I mean I'll just I
just wanted to play good chess and see
what happens is in this term as I've
been playing black holes the too often
so you've got white tomorrow yeah I
guess wyd but I guess used to play with
black he is so soon host kind of hard to
play was white because white we have to
push it was black I just you know I just
wait for them to come and get me and
then you know I go into gonna play and
then sometimes they was so it eats not
just this tournament you have a whole
bunch of stuff going on last night as a
member of chess coms pro chess league
st. Louis Archbishop's you guys made it
to the final four so go home team very
cool over across time cross town rivals
Webster University and also the big one
coming up the US Championship for the
first time ever you're participating
this is going to give you an opportunity
to mix it up with fabiano caruana Hikaru
Nakamura and Leslie so the captain of
the Archbishop's if nothing else but we
know he's one of the best in the world
of course what are your thoughts about
the US Championship well yeah I'm
obviously super pumped about it and very
excited to you know just even consider
the same words with such guys cuz you
know I'm really happy about the
opportunity to learn in the first place
you know like they will they can show me
something they can teach me something
you know I mean good results for myself
would have been if I can finish a
well lake in the first half let's say
the thermos I'll be very happy that
would be like max maximum probably what
I can hope for I mean provided that i'll
be in excellent shape and my opponent
sometimes we'll do some some bad things
you hope so and yeah actually I believe
the US Championship is also a qualifier
for the world cup and my goal is to
qualify for the World Cup to play again
and last time I played thousand lungs
and that was the best sermons of my life
inside may be right i still can try well
no one comes to the US Championship to
lose really but there's certainly a lot
more to gain than just the title of US
Champion so it's very exciting yarrow
congratulations and thank you for
joining me let's take a look after six
rounds of play the standings for group a
not many positions have changed in Group
A however Jeffrey Zhang has improved his
standing with a win today over Emilio
Cordova round seven on Friday March
seventeenth has zero book vs Howell
however if a winner emerges from hero
saya vs Zhang then we could be looking
at a new frontrunner as both players
sits at three and a half points one of
the mainstays of us chess grandmaster
Robert S came away with a victory today
in Group B with the white pieces against
Irene sook and our Robert
congratulations on the victory take us
through this game and show us what
happened absolutely so I panicked with
no time and again the pork Aucklanders
fish before King seven and now my idea
all along little Queen did before and
now that I had the opportunity to do it
I didn't so I don't really have a great
excuse for myself in this moment I guess
you know I've seeing ghosts that somehow
this pawn I thought was queening but it
doesn't have that opportunity I mean
all time just missing something I think
my king is in time to cover every cover
all my bases and if c1 Queen this looks
very scary rook see a check and bring
another piece into the action King be
too well I just kind of assumed I was
getting checking is here but after
roasting to check King III there are no
more checks to be had and all of a
sudden white with all the extra material
is doing really well so it just you know
my calculation was not extremely good at
this moment and with no time the clock
that's never a good thing so Queen d4
was better here did I made a losing move
on the f3 so out there takes takes this
is all actually force Bishop of three
check now sudden I'm in big trouble
because I mean assemble taking up my
rook over on h1 and I couldn't figure
out what my king on f2 or III were
better but we were both in pretty large
time travel she was down to a min and a
half I'm under a minute so I would King
III just to mix things up Quinn Bates h1
e6 so now I'm actually threatening Queen
g7 check woodhead least perpetual check
ideas but she played well as Queen g1
check taking away the g7 square and the
check is a temple begin move and I went
kingi for because i knew i was lost my
position is really bad now and I said
okay if I rhythmic hang up well she's no
check with her Queen besides repeating
over in h1 she's not going to do that
she if she takes on e6 with the pawn I
think she's still doing really well but
I figured okay now all of a sudden
there's some exposure in her position
may be my queen can sneak over anyone
and give a check over and h4 over them
before and that's the kind of counter
play I needed just with stay in the game
she went deep on check king d3 sharing
rook to see 8 I think she can also play
and move up to f8 because g7 is covered
so it looks possible to go Brooke at
veins are pinning down the F file I
think that's probably just winning
miscalculating which is very possible
but there's a huge issue here to bishops
not just one and I don't have anywhere
to really go with this one otherwise you
take on f1 will check and that's just
losing and if I go Queen a c1 protecting
well maybe now just cream the f2 is a
problem because again i have to move the
bishops wanted that for bishop but in
the f1 bishop falls behind it so that
was Irene I think easiest way to winter
in Brooks he ate Queenie one and he or
she just panicked and this is the reason
i want the game is she was c1 equals
queen which is a very poor move but i
understand why she did it i really
wanted to go Brooks before rain the
Queen to d4 with check but she got very
concerned and rightly so about Queen h4
check the point that now my Queens
getting out all of a sudden you know
maybe why has some hopes of surviving
but after King to eat I'm not seeing
another follow-up to white I think that
the king and just safely further back to
eight and this without a check on the
board with my vision hanging on f1 with
c1 queen coming with Queen d4 check you
know why is it toast it just this would
have been game over i can probably
safely resign but in time trouble you
get surging afraid of those type of
moves queen h4 check all done you're
very concerned Oh am I getting made it
always you know is there going to be a
drawing opportunity things like that and
so she made the in precise move see one
Queen and now if the bishop takes a c1
also i was really happy because it's
immensely complicated white has three
pawns in two bishops versus rook and
four and obviously both sides the queen
that's materially at least that's pretty
level you know working pawn with two
minors but with the king was wide open
bishops love open space so i was really
happy here inside work see for Bishop e3
queen g4 and again these are some in
precise moves probably I one King to be
too and here is the tragic blunder she
made me move pawn to d4 now my bishop is
attacking her work on c4 but she could
probably go rookie for it take the g6
pawn and I don't know who's better very
complicated
I still like having the bishops with the
open space but i'm losing my columns
quite quickly before the huge blunder
because Upton's move 39 those right
before Tommy Joel because either Bishop
takes before politics III check I think
what Irene forgot about is like King
doesn't I don't have to capture this
pawn yeah Queen tasty three-inch will
take on c4 and that's no that's no good
for white because I mean yes you know at
best it's going to be a draw try mean
for both sides at Bessie's draws there
should be a perpetual but King to c3 and
now the game just over I'm up full
bishop yeah there's this pawn on you
three but it doesn't really do anything
I'm up a piece for one pawn it just a
kind of trivial this point a matter of
simple technique and so after b5 I
decided to keep my H pawn on the board
because I figured I'd win the Queen's
I'd pond and now this is easy a queen
trade losses on the spot simply Queen
takes of six king cake and Bishop takes
me five and it's very easy i just put
additional he to eventually i'll win III
pond then i'll go in either the 8th a
part of the h-bond an extra bishop is
very simply Winnie and it's important to
note that if I did not have the eight
pound it would be a draw because this H
pawn is the wrong color wrong queening
square so I was very cautious when I was
thinking about these things because at
some point a 5 b-4 check happened upon
he traded well I'm I waiting chances are
lessened greatly and with the Queen's
and the boards of winning chances
without Queen that's the real dia
reticle draw so anyway Quinn ish will
check Kenya famous is just simple I'm
picking up her pond and after Queen t5
check came g8 Queen takes b5 extreme6
King reason she resigns it's not even
the check for for black because if you
check in the diagonal ice in cleveland
between as a queen e 6 Bishop c4 check
sorry no Chuck I'll stop a check but
I've come to Queen and you know
otherwise it's just a matter of time
where I get on the pond so yeah a pretty
hectic game this is my first bit of luck
in the tournament I think I've been
unlucky in certain games but um I guess
I pulled through and time crunch well
you stand 346
middle of the road here it looks like
bars pool attests that for grand prize
locked up essentially at this point but
what does this tournament plane in this
tournament mean to you well it means a
lot i haven't played serious chess in a
long time and i always have reasons as i
found myself declining events but when
st. Louis you know can knock on the
doors I hey Robert you know playing this
is strong tournament for Grandmaster
players I said absolutely that's what I
think US has been missing because of
course we have the single cup for elite
players we have the US Championships for
those who qualify but for players
especially younger players who are
up-and-coming and improving the same
settings of refined leaves jefferies
young Sam shank Andre Rob's and all
these guys I mean they're at this level
where a lot of them are over 2600 but
they lack in the u.s. opportunity to
play consistently against other 26
players so determine in my section is
lower than that but I thought was a
great opportunity i always love coming
to st. Louis they treat players better
than anywhere i've ever been treated a
chess tournament so for me yes i was
hesitant but then it became a no brainer
decision right I think that's the idea
you stated there those these seasonal
tournaments with this one be in the
debut the winter classic will have one
for every season to fit that void and
for people like yourself wrap before I
let you go what are you up to these days
you know if it's not chest what's going
on in the life rubber head yeah well
there's definitely a lot of chess I was
a coach in the u.s. women's team of the
Olympiad we did extremely well there I'm
always doing retesting those commentary
and analysis lecture and things like
that but what's up in my life I mean I'm
still running the sports quotient which
is a site i founded co-founded in
college it's to bring about smarter
sports analysis using statistical
backing rather than
you know the eye test was kind of I
guess my father's generation like the
how they are used to watching sports oh
this person's there's this person cuz i
say so but up statistic exactly i love
this yeah yeah so that's a than what my
folks is of course with a lot of chest
as well so let's have another playing
maybe this will be the start of
something new where i'll get back going
and playing chess again but other than
that it's sports quotient and a lot of
various chest well congratulations once
again Robert an idea on a great game
today and now after six rounds let's
take a look at the group be standing
Andre baarish pullets is on a roll
winning his last five straight the
player closest is still a point and a
half behind so it looks like Andre has
this one all but wrapped up on Friday
March 17 Irene sook and are the lowest
rated player in this field has an uphill
battle against baarish polis the 2017
winter chess classic runs every day
through sunday March 19th rounds begin
at one p.m. each day except for the
final round see the games live as they
happen on us chest champs calm and chest
24.com